tonight on Brian Ross investigates the
safety expert hired by USA Swimming to
protect its young athletes from sexual
assaults and abuse by coaches now
testifies the sport ignored his warnings
and recommendations as that
recommendation followed now in the way
that we had proposed will the president
of USA Swimming be able to keep his job
after testifying
he never even read the sports code of
conduct I have never heard it before
plus the Thomas Crown Affair in real
life two major art thefts overseas the
former head of security and America's
premier art museum weighs in is the
priceless art inside here safe could
someone steal a Vermeer from your Museum
I you know I can't say no I mean it's
possible how would they do it
and our shoutout for the college
newspaper doing it right prepared to
take on veteran beloved professors and
the school administration whatever the
consequences the fact that all of a
sudden someone that you've seen as a
mentor and interacted with so personally
is now you know there's an article
that's alleging that he's been
committing sexual misconduct and
harassment for 40 years from the law and
crime Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates good evening and welcome
we'll still be hearing about the coming
Summer Olympics being held in Tokyo this
year with American athletes already deep
into their training programs to make the
US team but what may Mar this glorious
event are the continued reports of
sexual abuse of athletes by coaches in a
number of sports with several lawsuits
scheduled to begin just as the games and
the trials are getting underway tonight
some new and troubling insights into how
one sport USA Swimming has handled or
failed to handle the troubling issues in
court last month testimony revealed a
serious gap between a rosy picture being
painted for the public and the harsh
reality here's the testimony of a
renowned sexual abuse expert dr. Victor
V
who was hired by USA Swimming only to
have his recommendations ignored as part
of this project is it true that
Gunderson and you recommended that USA
Swimming mandate that parents both
members of USA Swimming and parents of
children who are members of USA Swimming
undergo sex abuse training we
recommended that yes was that
recommendation followed not in the way
that we had proposed we proposed a
requirement and they proposed they were
going to do it in a different way the
incentive based model what is your
opinion as to the difference between
requiring parental training versus an
incentive incentive based program as far
as whether or not children are
vulnerable to sex abuse broader than
just my work in this case but 30 years
of experience parents just aren't going
to do it voluntarily very often you
don't know who which that testimony was
taken by lawyer Robert Allard who now
joins us from California by Skype mr.
Albert you sued USA Swimming on behalf
of a young swimmer who was sexually
molested by her coach in Stockton
California but the jury found in favor
of USA Swimming does that mean that USA
Swimming has been doing everything right
well the verdict came after a 1.1 to 5
million dollar settlement on behalf of
USA Swimming's regional arm here in
California called Pacific swimming as
well as its member club in Stockton
entitled the Stockton swim club so this
was simply a case against the National
Organization and based upon discussions
we had with the jury the decision had
nothing to do with any assessment of USA
Swimming's child protection program if
you want to call it that and everything
to do with the unique facts of our case
they did not like some of the things
they heard about the supervision of the
parents in particular and that was the
motivating factor behind their decision
so they sort of blamed the
victims parents in a way the testimony
of Victor veeth was that USA Swimming
decided not to require training for
parents and children but to have an
incentive based model what's the
difference there and what's the impact
of that well the incentive based program
really is for lack of a better term
laughable what they are saying is that
those who do the training get added
perks like pizza parties and things like
that
you will not find for example any
reduction in fees to USA Swimming if
people undergo the training which is
really what you should be doing if you
really want to incentivize parents but
Victor Vieth was the renowned expert
chosen by USA Swimming to do a complete
assessment of its program he clearly
told them that the voluntary program as
far as training was not working the
information was not getting out there
the statistics were very underwhelming
and recommended that they mandate
training very valuable training to
educate children how to protect
themselves from predators and parents to
learn about how these predators work and
it try to cut off the abuse by recognize
recognizing warning signs before the
abuse occurs there's really just no
reason why they didn't do that other
than it was just too much trouble is
what we heard and what the impact
required would be perhaps you know in
the 90 percentage people performing the
requirements and the training what about
this case were the incentive how how
widespread the training becomes well in
this case that we handled recently in
Stockton
no one had undergone safe sport training
no one had even heard of stage sport in
particular there was literally nothing
by way of child protection measures at
this club whatsoever and this is an
example as to things were finding out
about as we deal with these cases across
the country over and over again valuable
information by way of training and
education is not getting to the
grassroots level where the Predators
prey on kids and that's the most
important level you also took the
testimony of USA Swimming president and
CEO Tim Hinchey who told you under oath
he had never read the u.s. swimming
code of conduct here's a portion of that
testimony do you know enough about
grooming sir that it takes place over
time I'm not familiar with the grooming
takes place and when hen she was shown
training material produced by us
swimming itself laying out the warning
signs that predators can display in
grooming victims Hinchey admitted he had
never ever read it in the three years he
has run USA Swimming this is information
which is disseminated by USA something
as part of its training program is it
not I have never read it before have you
ever assessed whether or not pedophiles
are particularly attracted to the sport
of swimming
I have not again and again Hinchey
admitted his lack of knowledge about the
subject I'm just not familiar with all
the examples of grooming again I'm I
don't have the expertise to answer that
I just don't have the expertise as
relates to identifying what grooming is
before I read this information to you
had you been previously made aware of
this information not that I'm reading
today and hichy admitted he was even
unfamiliar with the USA Swimming code of
conduct at any point in time did you
receive any type of training on USA
Swimming his code of conduct did not as
you sit here today have you ever
reviewed in its entirety USA Swimming is
code of conduct
I have not stunning testimony mr. al are
you surprised he admitted to you he
never even read the code of conduct for
the sport that he runs I was stunned
especially since their position is that
parents and children should voluntarily
take on their own time review the
training materials now how as an
executive making hundreds of thousands
of dollars of years a year you expect
these parents and these kids to spend
the time to train themselves when he
himself had
hasn't even done it what's stunning to
me also is that almost 95% of USA
Swimming's members are children so what
you're saying is is that you understand
that there are pedophiles out there and
that they are affecting this sport
uniquely and yet you're not spending any
time to train yourself as to how
Predators get access to children it's
it's beyond stunning to me indeed Bob
Ballard a question to you from our
control room from executive producer
Rhonda Schwartz Rhonda you said you
didn't get exactly the outcome you
wanted in terms of suing USA Swimming
will this affect upcoming cases you have
another big case coming up right yes we
do we represent Arianna Cukor's and if
anything that this will benefit us
because we've now been through the
process we now know how they defend
these cases and the facts present in
that case in particular are far
different than they were in this case so
we see it as an advantage as far as us
learning in advance how they defend
these cases and more importantly an
expert they recently paid a hundred and
ten thousand dollars now imagine it a
hundred and ten thousand dollars is the
amount of money they paid to their
expert to comment on their liability
programs so we have an opportunity to
depose her and cross-examine her at
trial and I understand she'll be
testifying for them again and she'll be
a very wealthy lady Bob Bauer what's it
gonna take for you if they swing to
essentially wake up to this problem they
seem to be putting their head in the
sand
yeah the indifference shown by mr.
Hinchey tells me that this still is just
not even on their radar it's not
something they're paying attention to
and frankly I don't think it's anything
they care about they can say all they
want about how this is important about
how this is a commitment they're making
but what I see are things at the ground
level I see what happens to the children
when they're interacting with the
coaches and I'm here to tell you that
with the clubs I have dealt with
children are not protected from
predators at these clubs and until they
wake up and do something drastic at
least do what their own expert tells
them to do it's going to
in you so you're seeing continued cases
of sexual assaults and abuse by the
coaches against these young swimmers we
get calls weekly from swim clubs all
across the country and I have yet to see
a club with a child protection program
that is satisfactory and that will
adequately protect these kids so if that
sampling size is a representation as to
how it's happening across the country if
I were a parent and I was considering
putting my child in a swim program I
would think again and all this with the
Olympics coming up in USA Swimming
playing a big role yeah you know we see
a lot of attention about the Olympic
Games and you know millions of dollars
in corporate sponsorships and the Google
Awards whatever they have for their
goggles I don't see anything as far as
money spent and time devoted to an issue
which clearly needs to be resolved
alright Bob Allard thank you so much for
joining us tonight by the way we tried
to reach out for AUSA Swimming's comment
and no reaction to our requests thanks
Bob for coming on thank you thank you up
next after a major museum art theft in
Germany we'll talk with the man who ran
security at America's premier art museum
could it happen here
big news in the world of art and crime
these past few weeks with two daring
Museum break-ins and the loss of
priceless works so we wondered if US
museums could be just as vulnerable and
set out to meet someone who should know
the answer
both thefts were in Germany communist
era metals and jewelry taken from a
museum in Berlin clearly an acquired
taste but still valued in the hundreds
of thousands of dollars and of more
significance a theft at Dresden's royal
palace the thieves made off with a
priceless haul of jewelry where thieves
seen briefly on surveillance cameras
apparently disabled the museum's alarm
system by starting a fire and then made
off with 18th century jewelry officials
say the stolen jewelry could be worth up
to a billion dollars it's the kind of
thing that still worries the official
who set up security at America's premier
art museum John Borelli who's written a
new book stealing the show about his
more than three decades at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art in New York
there's probably no bigger target he
acknowledges given the art treasures
inside well I don't think any place has
anything like the Met in this country or
you know possibly in the world
the thing about the Met and what's in it
are the objects that are priceless and
they were approachable you can't replace
them do you have a sense that thieves
regularly case your Museum check it out
to see if there are any openings any
little deviations they can take
advantage of yeah I'm sure I'm sure it's
done every day by by visitors and then
we have the professional person who
planned something to take as they did at
tea at the Gardner Museum the theft at
the Gardner Museum in Boston was almost
30 years ago and remains unsolved
despite a 10 million dollar reward empty
frames hang where works by Rembrandt
Vermeer and daga once were on display
we've seen the Thomas Crown Affair
think of a large thieves like that could
they pull off a big theft at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art you know
anything's possible but in your view
it's it's I think it's Hollywood
basically even so some items did go
missing while Borelli wasn't charged
most notably this Grecian head which was
later recovered even though the person
who took it remains a mystery to this
day it was the first time this is an
interesting it was the first time in the
museum's existence that a piece of art
was taken from a public area well the
head wasn't secured properly to begin
with and the person had an opportunity
where he was able we say he because it
was very it was 23 pounds it was a heavy
head concealed it and he's ran out of
the building the theft was front-page
news in New York and five days later on
Valentine's Day we get a call from the
Manhattan south that they've recovered
the head out of a locker in Grand
Central Station you're still trying to
solve that gasps yeah that's an open
investigation
well I'm sure the statute of limitations
are over but you dr. know who took it
and yeah we would just like to know who
took it we want to know sort of what was
in this person's mind but as we
investigate
aasif we we really don't and as you get
further away from the theft all you
concentrate on is getting the piece back
recovery becomes paramount so you would
trade off recovering it for making an
arrest yeah yeah and I rest is secondary
it becomes that way yeah the art becomes
more important this priceless piece
becomes more important so in your years
there you really your greatest
achievement is there never was a major
theft of anything out in public display
could someone steal a Vermeer
your museum I you know I can't say no I
mean it's possible how would they do it
I'm not going to tell you that's right
well with the 30th anniversary of the
break-in at Boston's Gardner Museum just
a few months away no doubt we'll be
hearing a lot more about this up next
our shout out for the student newspaper
prepared to take on popular professors
and the school administration whatever
the consequences and our shout out
tonight for a college newspaper whose
beginner journalist it seems have been
doing everything right this comes at a
time when the paper at Northwestern
University famed for its journalism
school has been heavily criticized for
backing away and apologizing for a story
that fairly covered a student
demonstration the demonstrators didn't
like it too bad so it's all the more
impressive talk light the work of the
students at the University of Michigan
who have nothing to apologize for
with their hard-hitting journalism at
the Michigan daily we're the only daily
print publication in Ann Arbor the Ann
Arbor news shut its daily publication a
few years ago and since then we've we've
been kind of functioning as both a
school newspaper and a local newspaper
Maya Goldman is barely old enough to buy
a drink but she runs a 300 person
reporting staff as the editor-in-chief
of the University of Michigan student
newspaper that Michigan daily it's a
heavy obligation yeah it is it's a big
it's a big mantel as as my managing
editor says it's a lot of responsibility
but we take it very seriously it's a
privilege to and they do it very well
with a more robust operation than many
of the country's big city daily still
publishing covering news from both the
campus and from the city itself so that
includes you know news sports opinion
arts but then we also have a really
robust photo section we have a video
section podcast and we have a weekly
magazine called the statement we have a
section that's specifically a creative
Russian section for students of color we
have a copy desk that at it's pretty
much every story that goes in the paper
newspapers maybe dying in much of
America but this one seems alive and
well in Ann Arbor I think especially
after the 2016 election a lot of young
people were more interested in what is
real and how can I tell for myself if if
this information is correct and getting
involved in the you know a renewed
urgency to have a really strong freedom
of the press and a strong media culture
and with the recent investigative report
about a music professor accused of
sexual misconduct Goldman and her staff
quickly learned how to stand up to
pressure from those who don't want some
stories published do you really know
what you're doing do you really know how
this will affect people and how this
will affect the school but you know
we're totally we're completely
independent from the University we don't
receive any funding from them they have
no ownership over our content so you
know in that regard there was never
really a question the story was about
Professor Steven ships reported by semi
Sussman who uncovered undisclosed
allegations of sexual harassment sexual
misconduct and sexual relationships with
teenage students going back nearly 40
years it was my first time taking on any
sort of investigative reporting type
story Sussman a music school student
himself had to deal with divided
loyalties to his school and to his paper
I think that crossed my mind really
early in the reporting process before I
kind of understood the extent of the
alleged misconduct that was taking place
I will say that some faculty members I'm
a music student as I said so some
faculty members definitely pushed back
at me a bit for taking on this reporting
and damaging the brand but I don't think
it ever came from kind of the official
university channels a big story for even
a veteran reporter not to mention
someone just starting out in journalism
there were definitely there were a
couple of sleepless nights during the
reporting process and it's kind of
horrible to say but almost the amount of
alleged abuse that we were able to
uncover kind of made me less worried
about what we were doing I think it was
he was doing this for allegedly doing
this for 40 years of three separate
academic institutions Sussman story was
picked up across the state and the
professor has since retired after being
placed on leave by the University the
school says it is continuing to
investigate we were lucky that Sammy who
was only a sophomore at that time was
able to keep reporting and you know
wasn't the senior who was about to
graduate having Sammy's example and and
seeing at least for the staff now seeing
how much of a change that actually made
on campus and how impactful that process
was I think it really inspired a lot of
other people on our staff to want to do
more of that
indeed as someone who started as a
student journalist in Iowa there's no
better training to be had than working
for the school paper or radio or TV
station it can be challenging around the
time of finals but it's worth it that's
our program for tonight thanks for
joining us we'll see you back here next
week